this video is sponsored by ag1 use the
link in the description to receive a
free one-year supply of AG vitamin D3
and K2 and 5 travel packs with your
first purchase also for those interested
my brand new book the closer we get just
came out and is now available it's a
sort of reality bending psychological no
sugar-coating love story that I think
you'll really enjoy the link for that
will be in the description as well
before you even realized it you were
making decisions decisions that would
affect you your life Who You'd Be where
you'd end up and ever since then you've
been dealing with the consequences of
those decisions where they've put you
and what choices you need to make now
on average you will make somewhere
around 800 million decisions in your
lifetime most will be very small some
will be extremely significant
ultimately though every decision big or
small in some way or another will affect
you behind each is a different state of
being a different course of Life a
different condition of the world in
nearly every conscious waking moment you
exist at the intersection of the past
and future as a crossing guard for the
infinite possibilities of Life
understandably at least when it comes to
large important seeming decisions the
pressure of this position can be immense
as we attempt to the best of our
abilities to make the right decisions
should we move to a new place or shall
we stay where we've been should we
follow our passion or should we pursue a
more conservative career path which
people should we call friends which
should we no longer who should we date
and love who should we stop loving these
are a few of the very big life-changing
decisions that we will all inevitably
face within our lifetime there are
certainly cases in which these kinds of
decisions come with good reasons to
choose one way and not another and we
should strive to explore and discover
those reasons when we can we should run
cost benefit analyzes pros and cons
lists we should do our best to estimate
the outcomes and probabilities of
outcomes we should consult others we
should consider our intuition and scan
our body for physical signs of our
feeling about a choice do we contract or
tense up when we think about one option
and loosen and open up when we think
about another
but in truth often if not most of the
time with big hard decisions no matter
what we do and what we consider the
right choice will still be entirely
unclear
if you've ever made a pros and cons list
you've likely encountered an obvious
problem that emerges certain pros and
cons matter far more or less than others
it isn't enough to Simply tally them all
up and conclude that one side has 12
pros and six cons while the other has
nine and three what if one of the cons
is that you'll probably die surely that
would carry a greater weight in the
decision and so we have to define or
ascribe different degrees of weight or
quantitative value to each but how do we
ascribe clear quantitative value to
something like intuition feelings
variations of Happiness different senses
of purpose different kinds of Love of
hardship of Pleasure and Pain and so on
the point here of course is that when
imagining our life on the other side of
a big decision or any decision even if
our estimations of what it might be like
are anywhere near accurate which when it
comes to life our predictions are almost
never still how can we derive a
conclusion from all the abstract and
ambiguous elements in order to make a
so-called good or right decision
[Music]
we are led to believe by our Nature by
our culture by our hopes that there are
always better and worse options in life
go this way and life is good go that way
and life is bad or at least worse
sometimes this is the case sometimes
there are good reasons to believe it
will be but sometimes it is not the case
and there are no clear reasons sometimes
multiple scenarios appear to and do
carry equivalent amounts of possible
good possible bad possible risk possible
opportunity possible ambiguity and what
are we to do then how does one choose
between options if they are apparently
in some complex abstract way the same
and yet completely different
from a certain angle every reasonably
made decision in life will be wrong
every decision will cause pain sorrow
horrible challenges and deep suffering
no matter how good a decision is there
is no decision in life that will take
the very conditions of life away and so
as long as the decision keeps you alive
there will continue to be anxiety and
doubt and fear there will continue to be
the need to make new decisions in the
impulse to regret old ones
in truth we are far too hard on
ourselves our expectations are far too
high
German philosopher Arthur schopenhauer
wrote If you want a safe Compass to
guide you through life and to banish all
doubt as to the right way of looking at
it you cannot do better than accustom
yourself to regard this world as a
Penitentiary if you accustom yourself to
this view of life you will regulate your
expectations accordingly and cease to
look upon all its disagreeable incidents
Great and Small its sufferings its
worries its misery as anything unusual
or irregular nay you will find that
everything is as it should be
considering the problem of decision
making from an existentialist point of
view which is a key focus of the
philosophy explored by individuals like
Jean-Paul Sartre sorenkirgaard Albert
Camus and Friedrich Nietzsche what
matters in our decisions is often less
about what we choose and more about how
and why we choose the things we do as
well as how we respond to these
decisions and move forward sarcha argued
that we ought to make decisions
according only to honest and authentic
representations of our interests and
values he referred to making decisions
based rather on fearful deluded
conceptions of ourselves as bad faith
sorentergard suggested that we can
arrive at these authentic valuations of
ourselves by following what he referred
to as passion or a kind of intuitive
desire we must then take according to
Kierkegaard as he defined it a leap of
faith into what we personally determined
to be worthwhile and meaningful and not
necessarily and to what we think is
rationally or objectively right and both
kamu and Nietzsche help us deal with the
inevitable consequences that will come
from our choices and leaps of Faith by
reminding us that our attempts at
authenticity our plans and our projects
are all inevitably futile absurd and
destined to come with struggle and
suffering for Camus through his concept
of Revolt he argued that by recognizing
and affirming this absurdity we can
still happily live on in spite of it and
Nietzsche compels us to do just the same
with this concept of amor Fati Nietzsche
wrote my formula for human greatness is
Amor Fati that one wants nothing to be
different not in the future not in the
past not for all eternity not only to
endure what is necessary still less to
conceal it all idealism is falseness in
the face of necessity but to love it
[Music]
ultimately we are incapable of ever
making the decisions we truly want to
deep down the ones that will finally and
totally make life good and so when faced
with those hard crucial moments of life
rather than always worrying about making
the exact right perfect decisions
perhaps we ought to also focus on
perceiving and dealing with the
decision-making process ourselves and
our lives more charitably arguably
making decisions in life is a sort of
tightrope walk between taking them at
least important ones very seriously
while simultaneously knowing that no
matter how seriously we take them it
won't matter all that much and the way
we conventionally hope it will
in the same way that from a certain
angle every decision is some amount
wrong so too is every reasonably made
decision from a certain angle right sure
to lead to beautiful experiences great
triumphs and deep meaning
in every decision and every moment where
we are still alive no matter what is
good or bad we have the chance to stand
behind our decisions move forward
through them with honesty and effort and
to embrace the incoming conditions of
life with admiration and Grace and in
doing so we have the opportunity to
transform whatever conditions our
decisions have led us to into meaning
and value and Beauty
in the end Perhaps it is not the
specific decisions that we make that
will give our lives their meaning but it
is how we perceive the life our
decisions have led us to that will give
our lives their meaning
this video was sponsored by ag1 of
course in addition to very difficult big
ambiguous decisions in life they're also
much easier more obvious decisions we
make every day which also invariably
affect the course of Our Lives we are
what we repeatedly do Excellence then is
not an act but a habit wrote will Durant
one of those fairly obvious easy but
important decisions is taking care of
our body and getting the proper
nutrition although this choice is easy
to make actually executing on it on a
regular basis can be extremely
challenging time consuming and
overwhelming with ag-1 however the whole
process is made simple easy and
efficient ag1 is perfect for everyone
but especially anyone who struggles with
too many options or wants to optimize
their time because it combines 75
vitamins minerals Whole Food sourced
ingredients and packs in the perfect
amount of micronutrients absorption and
taste so that the decision to support
your whole body health is just one scoop
and ounces of water every day with its
science driven formulation of prebiotics
probiotics and plant-based enzymes ag-1
supports long-term gut health and with
CoQ10 and phytonutrients it promotes
longevity and health for the skin brain
and heart and every day through keeping
your body nourished and replenished you
feel that increased healthy alertness
focus and balance
start your day off with an easy decision
with ag-1 by going to drinkag1.com
pursuit of wonder by using my link
you'll also receive a free one-year
supply of immune supporting vitamin D3
and K2 plus 5 free travel packs with
your first purchase
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]